hi tyra it's so amazing to meet you
nice to meet you i was a big fan of
america's next top model back in the day
i was obsessed with it
um okay so obviously right off the bat
we have to talk about cheryl what was
sort of your reaction when you found out
oh i was just like disheartened and sad
and hoped that she's okay and then heard
she was vaccinated so made me feel
better and um so yeah all that went you
know through my through my head just
making sure that she's okay then i was
like cody is he safe like you know so
it's like your mind starts going through
all of that um and then you know i just
was concerned and wanted to make sure
that his chances didn't suffer because
what they were going through so it was
great that the rehearsal was totally
recorded
and able to be shown
i think i could speak for everyone when
i'm when i say i'm so excited to see
cody do britney week next week oh my
gosh beyond
i was like he has to make it um
it's going to be something special i'm
sure
i don't like how um how did this all
come about was this sort of just
something you know from the very
beginning of the season that you were
like you guys were like we have to do
brittany
yeah i mean britney is a living legend
she's an icon and of course we all know
that she's going through a lot right now
and it's important to celebrate her and
to celebrate the greatness that she is
and yes she's going through a tough time
but we cannot forget
that she's brittany
you know and she deserves to be
celebrated in all of her glory and we
are going to do that and give her the
the respect that she deserves
i love that um
last thing about cheryl uh will cheryl
be able to participate next week if she
tests uh negative or is that still up in
the air
you know i don't know i'm not the
officer so i'm the covenant officer
there's a whole thing
so that goes a bit beyond me at the
moment um and also i'm an ep but i'm
also on stage for two hours live so i
don't know what's happening on the
business side uh when i'm on stage got
you got you well um how has how would
you describe i mean obviously you know
the new development on sunday sort of
threw everything for a loop but how
would you describe your sophomore season
of being the host of dancing with the
stars so far yeah um you know i feel a
lot more confident to say what i need
um so when i see something not working
before it was like this is not working i
don't know why now i'm like i know why
it's working and this is what it's going
to take uh to make this one smoother to
make this better
so i feel a lot more confident to say
that just based on experience now
yeah um
obviously last season there wasn't any
audience there's still a very small one
but do you feel like that even makes a
difference a bit
um
you know i actually like both seasons i
the the last season with the dancers up
in the balcony they were so loud
and so rowdy
that to me i felt like sometimes they
were louder than the audience that we
have now there was just a few of them so
i like both i do
um is there a moment or somebody from
the season who's really stood out to you
or a couple people who you just were
sort of surprised by or just really
touched by their story
jimmy allen to me today was so beautiful
and so vulnerable and then to see him
dance he's got this mix of these
beautiful lines a little bit of soul a
little bit of country like i did not
expect him to dance like that he has
something very special and i did i
didn't expect it
um you know obviously it's the 30th
season
which is just crazy on its own that a
show has been around for 30 seasons um
what is sort of dancing with the stars i
know you're a host but you you know it's
you watched it before what is sort of
dancing stars mean to you
it means to me taking people out of
their comfort and putting them into this
place that they don't know what the hell
they're doing
in general of course we have some people
with dance backgrounds um but it's not
ballroom and everybody's watching and
you are really hugely great at something
in your craft and that's why dancing
with the stars calls to pull you into
something that you're not necessarily
great at so there's vulnerability
there's glamour there's upset and
happiness and there's there's so much
beauty and it's also a show that the
whole family can watch
like when i go home uh my son because it
starts on the west coast when i get home
and my son is
and he connects with the show